Welcome back to State of the Union.
It may be days before
all the votes are counted,
but Republicans are already
pointing fingers at one another
with GOP lawmakers
in both the House and the Senate
criticizing their leadership
for failing to meet expectations
Just as former President
Trump teases a special announcem
next week.
Here with me
now, a Republican governor
who's led a blue state
Maryland since 2015.
Larry Hogan.
Governor,
thank you so much for joining me
Good morning.
You've kind of been on an island
and maybe a few others are with
as a Republican warning
against GOP extremism
and specifically election denial
How do you interpret the results
Well, yeah,
I've been talking about this for
and it seemed as if I was the on
talking about it.
But today
there are a whole lot more peopl
talking about it
than the way I would interpret i
Look, this was this
should have been a huge red wave
It should have been
one of the biggest red waves
we've ever had because
you know,
President Biden's
approval rating was so low,
one of the lowest historically,
more than 70% of
people thought the country was g
in the wrong direction.
And yet we still didn't perform.
And I think commonsense conserva
that focused on talking about is
people cared about, like the eco
and crime and education, they di
But people who tried to relitiga
the 20, 20 election
and focused on conspiracy theori
you know, talked about things
the voters didn't care about,
they were almost universally rej
And I think
it's basically
the third election in a row
that Donald Trump has cost us th
And it's like,
you know, three strikes, you're
Well, do you think that's true?
Because we've heard
that after one strike and two st
do you keep your analogy going?
Well, you know,
that's a definition of insanity.
Is doing the same thing
over and over again,
expecting a different result.
And, you know, Donald Trump
kept saying,
and we're going to be winning
so much, we'll get tired of winn
I'm tired of losing.
I mean, that's all he's done.
So you don't think that this
is just a blip
and that Republicans will return
being what's kind
of still the party of Trump,
but embracing the party of Trump
You think this time is different
You know, if you
if you lose
over and over again to
what's really not that great of
you've got to reassess.
Is it time to rebuild?
And you have to go back and thin
how do we have a more
hopeful, positive vision?
How do we appeal to a broader
group of voters?
Because we've know
in some cases
we fired up the base, but we tur
five wide swaths of swing voters
and it's why we didn't perform.
Former President Trump
is teasing a very big announceme
on Tuesday night. Huge.
He could announce his 20, 24 bid
to run for president again.
What do you think will happen if
Well, there's no question he's
still the £800 gorilla and it's
still a battle.
It's going to continue
for the next two years.
I would just say that we're
two years out from the next elec
and we're just trying to
you know,
the dust is settling from this o
I think it'd be a mistake.
As I mentioned,
Trump's cost us the last three e
and I don't want to see it happe
a fourth time.
Could it cost by if he does anno
could he cost Republicans
the runoff in Georgia?
No. Question about that.
I mean, that's not as consequent
Now, we still would like to win
but we're not going to win back
the Senate as a result.
And that's Donald Trump's fault.
I have to ask you about somethin
that he posted
on his social media website
with social use,
a racist comment
to lash out
at another potential 2024 compet
your fellow Republican
governor, Glenn Youngkin,
he wrote Youngkin
separating his last name.
Now, that's an interesting take.
Sounds Chinese, doesn't it?
In Virginia couldn't have won wi
Your wife
and children are Korean-American
You've made a point
of fighting against Asian-Americ
hate as governor.
What's your reaction to that?
Well, it was definitely distaste
and inappropriate,
not only because I don't think m
Glenn Youngkin
deserved to be attacked like tha
but it was also.
I mean, it's Asian hate
against a white governor,
you know, and making fun of Asia
And he didn't even have
his nationalities. Right.
Because Youngkin would be
Korean as opposed to Chinese.
But it's just more of the same
from Donald Trump insults and at
And that's one of the reasons wh
the party is in such bad shape.
Is it racist? It is racist.
One Republican who had
an unequivocally strong election
night was another
one of your fellow Republican
governors, Ron DeSantis in Flori
A growing number of Republicans
similarly to you
about Trump saying
we have to move
ahead are saying, well,
maybe Ron DeSantis is our guy.
Would he make a good president?
Well, he certainly had a great n
The other night in Florida
was a big win for Ron DeSantis.
Florida is becoming more
and more red as a result.
Of I think there are 600,000
new Republicans in Florida
because they're
it's kind of flight
out of the blue states into Flor
It was a
he did a great job picking up
Hispanic voters
and in Miami and then in South F
which is kind of what we did
in our lives race.
We won Hispanics,
but it was a good night for him.
And he's certainly
one of the important voices for
for the party.
It's no secret
that you are considering
running in 20, 24.
What is your status now?
Will you run?
Well, I'll tell you what I'm doi
You know,
I'll be heading down to Florida
with all my fellow governors.
We're all going to talk about
what happened and we're going to
a couple of new governors.
And then I'll be flying out.
I'll do a thing with RJC.
I'll be on the stage
with Mike Pence and Mike Pompeo.
And at the end of the month,
I'm going to have a big thing
in Annapolis, a summit.
We're going to be bringing peopl
from all around the country.
And I'm going
have a big celebration
of our eight years of success.
And we're going to take a look
I stuff to do my day job
until January 18th,
and then I can walk and chew gum
at the same time.
Yeah, what's true?
I'll be freed up and unleashed.
And will you?
When will you be unleashed
toward the 20, 24 run?
I think there's probably,
you know, I've been saying since
that we have to get back to a pa
that appeals to more people
that can win in tough places
like I've done in Maryland.
And I think that line is much wi
now than it was a week ago.
One quick question before I let
Kevin McCarthy is working the ph
He wants to be speaker.
If Republicans do take the House
should he be?
You know,
I think most Americans aren't
paying much attention to palace
and what's going on.
I know the focus of efforts
are constitutional.
Most people,
you know,
the inner
battle about who might be in cha
You know, look,
I think the the
the people on the far right
really lost this election.
And now they want
to try to take that over.
But it's got to be a very slim m
Kevin McCarthy, we've got work t
is there's no question about tha
Governor Larry Hogan, thank you
Appreciate it. Thank you.
Nice to see you.